my favorite Frozen is Orange Leaf I
believe that they have the best flavors
I think the founder of that franchise or
whatever it is actually loves dessert
you can tell by the attention to detail
by the cookies that they bring in
they're always fire they're so good the
flavors themselves are decadent they
don't have all these weird fruit things
it's just like caramel chocolate peanut
butter you know what I mean the good
stuff that is my personal favorite of
all the different yogurt stores and if
you haven't been to an orange leaf you
should check it out they're very good I
was not paid to say that they are very
good though